- Okay.
Welcome everybody.
I'm Maurice Samuels,
the director of the Yale Program
for the Study of Antisemitism,
and it's my great pleasure
to welcome you today
to this hybrid lecture,
both in person and on Zoom.
It's our first attempt to
do a hybrid format here.
So the way it's gonna work is
that I will introduce Professor Feinberg.
He's gonna speak for about 40 minutes,
and then we'll take 20
minutes of questions
from the audience, both
in person and on Zoom.
So, those of you on Zoom,
we ask you to submit your
questions using the Q&A function
at the bottom of your screen,
the chat function is disabled.
And then we will ask
in-person, Professor Feinberg,
your questions that you
submit in the Q&A function.
And you can submit those questions
at any time during the lecture.
You don't have to wait until the end.
So, I'll now introduce Professor Feinberg.
Ayal Feinberg is one of
the leading researchers,
doing quantitative
analysis of antisemitism,
an extremely valuable
contribution to the field.
He is associate professor
of political science
and antisemitism studies,
and is the director of the
Center for Holocaust Studies
and Human Rights at Gratz College,
overseeing the largest holocaust
and genocide graduate
program in the world.
His research has been widely featured
in leading international
journals and media outlets,
and his scholarship is frequently utilized
by practitioners and
policymakers concerned
with the insecurity of marginalized groups
and the perseverance of
the Jewish community.
In addition to all of this,
and in addition to his academic position,
he's also a quantitative research fellow
at the Anti-Defamation League Center
for Antisemitism Research.
And he recently completed
a three-year term
as the junior faculty chair
at the Academic Engagement Network.
His antisemitic bias incident
analysis was inducted
into the congressional record,
during the 2019 House
Judiciary Committee's hearing
on hate crime and the
rise of white nationalism.
His talk today is entitled,
"Clarifying Antisemitism
Through Experiments:
Exploring Blame,
Responsibility, and Hate Crime."
So please join me in welcoming
back to Yale, Ayal Feinberg.
- Thank you for
that very, very kind
introduction, Professor Samuels.
Very excited to be back at Yale
to be presenting some of
the experimental research
that I'm doing along with my
colleague Dr. Jacob Scott Lewis
at Washington State University.
A lot of this research
is pretty new for us,
and we're really excited to begin
to share this research with the public.
So we really welcome all of
your questions, your comments,
and ways that we can improve upon
and build on this research.
So the title, as Dr. Samuel said,
is "Clarifying Antisemitism
Through Experiments:
Exploring Blame,
Responsibility, and Hate Crime."
Sorry, everyone, just
getting the clicker ready.
Okay, I think it's critical
to talk about why I'm
engaged in this process.
Although I'm proud that my research is
as objective as I'm able to design it,
I am motivated by an
overarching normative concern
about violent antisemitism.
And I think that these
three images share a lot
of important elements that
we need to be thinking
about when we're constructing
anti-Semitism research today.
I think most people are
familiar with this image
on the right of the Tree
of Life Synagogue Memorial,
outside of the Tree of Life,
after the most lethal antisemitic attack
on American Jews in our country's history.
On the left is the AMIA
attack in Buenos Aires,
an attack that most American Jews,
are far less familiar with,
but resulted in 87 fatalities.
Many considered this attack
to be the most lethal antisemitic
attack post-Holocaust.
And what's really critical
here as we struggle
with understanding the role
of anti-Israel sentiment
and anti-Zionism and
explaining antisemitism,
is a image from the riots that happened
in South France in 2014,
where Jewish businesses
and Jewish individuals,
are indiscriminately targeted
because of the behavior of Israel.
Clicker struggles continue.
Sorry, everyone, give me one second.
Okay, success, all right.
There is concern surrounding
rising antisemitism here
in the United States.
There is a general feeling
that Jews are less safe.
How do we know this?
What are the empirics
that we're utilizing to
base this information on?
Well, the AJC has done a survey
of the American Jewish population
where they ask several questions
that help us to determine the
security of Jewish Americans.
One of the questions that they
frequently ask in the survey,
"Do you think that
antisemitism is a problem
in the United States?"
From the most recent
iteration of the survey,
89% of Americans say that
antisemitism is a problem
in the United States.
In fact, this number hovers between
about 80 and 95% in any given year.
It doesn't tell us a great deal
at an individual level
about Jewish insecurity,
but what I think helps us
to articulate the current
situation quite greatly is
that 82% of American Jews believe
that antisemitism has increased.
There is a feeling that there
is increasing antisemitism.
These numbers are higher
than many previous years,
and that 41% of American Jews
report feeling less secure,
than a year ago.
Only 4% feel more secure.
Again, these numbers seem to show
that there is a new increased feeling
of insecurity amongst American Jews.
The other thing that we often do is look
to the surveys where we ask
about antisemitic trope alignment.
So the ADL has offered up
many surveys since 1964,
using the same question battery aimed
at measuring the number of
antisemitic trope alignment
that exists amongst the
American population.
What do we see?
A big difference, from 2019 to 2022.
This gap, 20% of Americans constitute
about 54 million Americans that now fall
into the category of those that align
with at least six of the
11 antisemitic tropes
that the ADL measures.
Okay, so a little bit about
what I'm going to be doing today
in this presentation,
I wanna do a little bit
of housekeeping first.
I never know exactly who my audience is,
so I think it's important
to do a brief overview
of antisemitism, and share a little bit
about antisemitism empirics.
I'm gonna talk to you and
provide you an overview
of some of the experimental literature
that already examines antisemitism.
And then I'm gonna share
two of my own experiments
that I've done, again,
with Jacob Scott Lewis
at Washington State,
exploring blame, attribution
and responsibility to speak out
as well as the effects
of hate crime exposure
on foreign policy preferences.
And then I'm gonna tease everybody
with a little bit of future survey.
So let's start with defining antisemitism.
A tremendous amount of time, resources,
and concern surround how
do we define antisemitism.
It's one of these enduring questions.
On the left is the IHRA
definition of antisemitism.
Seen by many as a gold standard,
or a way that institutions
can adopt a definition
that best protects Jews in part,
because of how IHRA
provides specific examples
of when anti-Zionism
constitutes antisemitism.
On the right is the
ADL's definition, right?
The ADL, one of the leading
organizations concerned
with Jewish safety and insecurity.
Happy to go over some of the differences
that we see in these
definitions in the Q&A,
but I wanted to make sure
that we were provided a
definition of antisemitism.
Every presentation that
I give on antisemitism,
I include this quote
from historian populists,
because I think it's critical
that when we evaluate
antisemitism, we understand
that no perpetrator
ideology owns antisemitism.
As we see antisemitism being weaponized
on the left and the right,
it's important to remember
that antisemitism manifests
in a multitude of ways.
Jews are always showing off.
They are hermetic and secretive.
They will not assimilate.
They assimilate only too well.
They are too religious,
they're too materialistic,
and a threat to religion.
They're uncultured, they
have too much culture.
They avoid manual work,
they work too hard.
They are miserly, they're
ostentatious spenders.
They're inveterate capitalists,
they're born communist, and so on.
In all its myriad manifestations,
the language of antisemitism
through the ages is
dictionary of non-sequiturs
and antonyms, a thesaurus of
illogic and inconsistency.
What are these enduring
questions that I mentioned?
Things that we struggle with
that we don't yet have
generalizable answers to,
but are absolutely
critical in how we seek,
measuring, and tracking antisemitism.
First and foremost, who is a Jew?
Is being Jewish something that's scalable
or is it binary?
Understanding this is absolutely critical,
and there is, again,
no generalizable agreement
on what constitutes this.
Most survey research, a lot of
the work that I'm gonna share
with you today
that explores specifically
Jewish perceptions,
much of this comes from the idea
of self-reporting one's Jewish identity.
What is antisemitism?
How do we define antisemitism?
Should we even use the term antisemitism?
AJC did some recent
polling on this that said,
"An enormous proportion of Americans,
near the majority of Americans,
don't know how to define antisemitism."
I haven't really heard of it.
So perhaps, we should push
towards using alternative terms
that most Americans
would be able to identify
as representing Jew hate.
There's a movement to
suggest that we should,
instead of using antisemitism,
use the term, Jew hate.
Of course, I mentioned
the IHRA definition,
we saw a lot of concern regarding this,
when Biden rolled out his new
plan to combat antisemitism.
What definition should we use?
Because if we're not all
utilizing the same definition,
we're not all calling the
same balls and strengths.
Should we be using JDA?
We have Nexus, we have
several other definitions
of antisemitism that we should consider.
And then of course, anti-Israel,
anti-Zionist beliefs,
when does holding specific
anti-Israel sentiment
or when does manifestation of
specific anti-Zionist beliefs,
actually constitute antisemitism if ever?
No generalizable agreement here.
Other things that I think
we should consider are
measurement concerns.
We do a lot of research.
Most of the tracking that we see,
most of what Americans are
exposed to are either allies
of hate crimes or some
of the survey results
that I already shared today.
Attitudes and behavior.
While we like to think that
these are connected and linked,
in reality, their relationship
is far less clear.
So we need to be exploring research
that really connects specific attitudes
to particular manifestations
that we're most concerned.
What about antisemitism and philosemitism,
philosemitism being those that love Jews?
These two phenomenon are not only linked,
sometimes when you measure them,
they show up in the exact same ways.
Some people have gone as hard to say
that philosemitism in and of itself,
is a form of antisemitism.
So it's critical as
we're trying to decipher
what constitutes antisemitism,
are we measuring antisemitism,
are we measuring philosemitism,
are these terms the same?
And especially, in the United States,
what many have called the
most philosemitic country
in the world, this is an important thing
that we have yet to truly
figure out in the discipline.
And then of course, latent antisemitism.
When we think about racism,
even those that are the most
virulent racists and bigots,
they don't always wear
that on their sleeve.
It doesn't define their
every action and opportunity.
Often, it takes a certain stimulus
to induce an element
of racism and bigotry.
Much of antisemitism is like,
so how do we measure a phenomenon
that isn't necessarily
empirically available for us?
I also wanna talk a little bit
about general measures of antisemitism.
When it comes to our choices
in doing quantitative research,
we can look at events.
This often constitutes acts of terror,
hate crime variation,
bias incident variation.
We can look at social media
methods on tweets, YouTube,
Facebook, TikTok, not
just the content itself,
not just content frequency,
but the responsiveness of
these various platforms
in removing the content,
how quickly they remove it.
Are they removing it
for certain actors only?
Does it take a specific
act to report the content
in order to remove it?
And this has become very
important, of course,
with Elon Musk's takeover of Twitter, X,
and his concern regarding
the ADL in that fact.
Policy.
We can look at governmental
discrimination.
Here in the United
States, we'd like to think
that there is no longer
governmental discrimination,
targeting Jews, but across
Europe and in many other places,
Jews are not always able to
practice their religion freely.
Societal discrimination and
institutional discrimination,
are other outlets that we can
use to measure antisemitism.
There's interesting work
that's now being done
through network analysis,
looking at organizational connections,
looking at group mapping,
looking at extremist networks.
How are hate groups organizing?
How are they building content?
How are they building followers?
And then of course, attitudes and beliefs.
What we commonly evaluate through surveys,
but also through interviews,
focus groups, and experiments.
We are having a few technical issues.
Okay, common descriptive
approaches, right?
What we most frequently see, surveys.
One of the biggest
challenges we have here is
that antisemitism, as I mentioned,
is an extremely challenging
phenomena to measure.
In 2022, the ADL changed its battery
that hadn't changed since 1964.
We added three questions
and we changed some of the balances.
What do we see?
At the very top,
when asking a nationally
representative sample,
70% of Americans say that,
"Jews stick together more
than other Americans."
Report that's at least
mostly or somewhat true.
At the bottom, 16% mostly say
mostly are somewhat say that,
"Jews are not as honest
as other business people."
Antisemitism is multi-factor.
There are many ways in
which it can manifest.
So any survey that attempts
to measure it has these challenges.
How do we measure all of these
elements of antisemitism?
We can look at incident reporting,
and the ADL audit report is
something that's very common.
The FBI's hate crime report
that comes out annually is another way
that we can evaluate
antisemitic incident variation
in antisemitism in the United States.
The tremendous amount of money is going
to fund interventions
and to generate policy
that combats antisemitism
through these primarily
descriptive approaches.
What I contend is that
we need to go further.
We need to do more rigorous
quantitative analysis.
We need to understand the mechanisms
that explain why certain
attitudes are more likely
to lead to antisemitic behavior.
Through the experimental work
that I and others are pursuing,
I'm hoping that that's gonna be the case.
So why experiments?
Experiments offer us a really unique way
to isolate specific factors
and correlates we think explain
variation in antisemitism.
It helps us to evaluate
what are the structures of antisemitism.
In some cases, as I mentioned
with latent antisemitism,
what are the conditions
that elevate antisemitism?
What's the relationship between attitudes
and policy preferences?
Something I'm gonna share
today with our research
that explores hate crime exposure,
and how does an exposure to a
specific narrative or event,
all to belief in a traditional
marketing sense message test?
It's important to note, right,
as I promote an experimental approach
to understanding antisemitism,
there are shortcomings that
we are constantly consider;
the pollster effect
or what many have known
as interviewer effect.
The emergence of specific
characteristics of the messenger
or the deliverer of a certain
question altering the way
in which a respondent approaches it.
One of the ways that you
can do that is to make sure
that you have multiple
different characteristics
of any sort of enumerator,
any person that's responsible
for delivering it,
and to evaluate whether
or not there is this
messenger effect in place.
A bogus pipeline.
A way to avoid some of the
social desirability concerns
of a potential respondent.
Let them know that in fact
we are able to detect when they're alive.
And then of course, pure
control and vignette control.
This is something my
colleague, Jacob Scott Lewis,
and I are very interested in is whether
or not we should be looking
simply at a pure control,
those that aren't exposed
to any sort of treatment,
or whether we should also
provide an innocuous treatment,
and whether or or seemingly
innocuous treatment
and whether or not that actually
creates different findings.
So I'm gonna go over briefly now,
some of the most important
pieces of experimental literature
in evaluating antisemitism.
This is largely focused on
the work of Michal Bilewicz
at University of Warsaw,
who is the leading expert when it comes
to antisemitism experimentation.
So one of the main beliefs
is that it's important
for us as scholars to create
typologies of antisemitism.
What are the factors that
explain antisemitism?
Bilewicz et al. in 2013,
focus on authoritarian
personality characteristics.
They focus on victimhood-based
social identity.
They focus on relative deprivation.
And they examine whether
or not this manifests
in these factor loadings here of focusing
on a three-factor
structure of antisemitism,
conspiratorial antisemitism,
traditional religious
and anti-Judaic beliefs, and
secondary antisemitic beliefs,
those that focus on
Holocaust commemoration.
They looked at a population
in Poland to do this work.
What they're able to find is
that specific factors of antisemitism help
to explain variation in
how somebody would choose
to donate resources
to commemorating certain
elements of history.
Specifically that antisemitic beliefs
and holding of antisemitic
beliefs, the possession of it,
and the strength of those beliefs,
help to make one choose
to provide those resources
to a museum that's not
associated with the Holocaust,
but instead of broader national museum.
So what this shows here,
what the summary shows is that those
that hold traditional antisemitic beliefs,
secondary antisemitic beliefs,
and belief in Jewish conspiracy,
all donate less money
to Jewish organizations.
A lot of concern is focused
on the contact hypothesis.
For those that are not familiar
with the contact hypothesis originating
with all court in 1954,
what Stefaniak et al. do
in 2022 is a meta-analysis
of eight different studies
evaluating active engagement
with historical ethnic
diversity in Poland.
The idea here was to provide
a specific curriculum
for students across Polish high schools,
and to evaluate whether or not engaging
in this curriculum with Jews
helps to reduce antisemitism.
Participation in the
intervention contributes
to building knowledge and
interest in local history,
more positive attitudes
towards Jewish people,
and toward ethnic diversity in general.
Attendees of this program,
developed stronger place attachment
in civic engagement intentions.
But their general social trust
and attitudes toward other
ethnic groups, the Roma people,
remained largely unchanged.
So this element, this
program, this curriculum,
works in the reduction of antisemitism,
but it is not nearly as effective
in reducing broader forms prejudice.
A lot of individuals are concerned
with the notion of power and antisemitism,
but also powerlessness and antisemitism.
What happens when people
lose their agency?
What happens when there's a lack of power,
a lack of control and
feelings of uncertainty?
So first and foremost,
we know that lack of
control and uncertainty
in the political domain
are highly interconnected.
Political uncontrollability,
rather than political uncertainty,
predicts individual's beliefs
in Jewish conspiracies.
So, what happened in this case
with this research design?
One group was given a vignette
that focuses on political
uncontrollability.
The other was given a vignette
that looks at political uncertainty.
And what they find is
that it's the uncontrollability
not uncertainty,
it's the lack of agency that helps
to explain individual's
beliefs in Jewish conspiracies.
Political uncontrollability, they find,
predicts belief in Jewish conspiracy,
even after controlling
for antisemitic discriminatory attitudes,
even when you control proprietor beliefs.
The same study also shows
that lack of control may
be specific particularly
to conspiracy stereotypes of Jews,
and less specific to groups not viewed
as prototypical conspiring agents.
It's specific to Jews,
not Germans, not Russians.
There's a direct
relationship between feelings
of lack of control and
general conspiracies,
but that belief is weak,
and there's an increase
in the endorsement of
conspiracy stereotypes
of Jews driving other conspiracy beliefs.
Great work from Antoniou
et al. in 2015 and 2020,
focusing on the Greek context.
They're really interested
in understanding this notion
of competing and collective victimhood.
Antisemitism stems from a
sense of collective victimhood,
defined as a perception
that an individual's nation,
has been a victim of history
that is rooted in the
historical narrative found
in education, and other socialization age.
So, what do they do?
Right, they provide specific vignettes
that are aimed at increasing a sense
of comparative victimhood or collectively.
What they find is that
inducing ingroup favoritism,
leads any group members
to downplay the collective
suffering of others.
This manifests through
antagonism with other groups,
widely acclaimed as victims
over the moral benefits emerging
from victimhood status.
So to put it simply, there's
a competition over victimhood
that they're identifying
through this process.
Now, I think this is an
experiment that really is useful
for understanding a lot
of what's manifesting
in America today as it
relates to hate speech,
as it relates to antisemitic
social media content.
The Soral et al. piece
shows that lower sensitivity
to hate speech, was a positive mediator
of the relationship
between frequent exposure
to hate speech and outgroup prejudice.
They provided desensitization
trait, and what they found is
that after you desensitize
somebody to hate speech,
individuals were less
sensitive to hate speech
and more prejudice towards
hate speech victims,
than their counterparts that
were in the control condition.
Those that did not receive
that desensitization drink.
The effects of exposure to
hate speech on prejudice,
were mediated by a lower
sensitivity to hate speech,
and not buy lower
sensitivity to social norms.
And the last piece that I
wanna show you before going
into my own work is the
mortality salience piece
and the double standards piece
that was done by Florette
Cohen et al. in 2009.
The effect of mortality salience,
and when we say mortality salience,
the idea of bringing up the idea of death.
The effect of mortality
salience on increasing support
for punishing countries that
commit human rights violations,
was most strongly apparent
in the Israel condition.
So, when you expose somebody
to this idea of death,
it manifests with specific
anti-Israel sentiments
and an increase in antisemitism.
Because antisemitism may
increase hostility to Israel,
it's hard to parse things out.
And this is some of what
I'm trying to do now
with my experimental work.
So my work is long focused
on what we call the
homeland-diaspora nexus,
understanding the role
of Jewish attachment
and identity as it relates to Israel,
but also how Israeli behavior
and perceptions of Israeli
behavior affect the identity
and insecurity of Jews.
This is really a combination
of what I'd say are several disciplines,
international relations, antisemitism,
and those that focus on hate crimes,
law and criminology,
and a lot in sociology.
The main research question
that I'm interested in answering is,
what is Israel's role
in explaining variation
in antisemitic events and hate crimes?
I did a piece in 2019
that really explored this in
the European context, right?
We've seen a lot as it relates
to some descriptive statistics
about spikes in antisemitism
when Israel's engaged
in a violent conflict in the Middle East.
Operation protective edge,
looking at France and UK here,
we see a massive spike in the month
that Israel's engaged in that operation,
only to decline back to
normal levels just a month
or two later.
When I looked at data from 2009 to 2017,
evaluating any month
where Israeli casualties
from war exceeded 100,
we see a 35% rise in
antisemitic hate crimes
that are reported across
28 European states.
I also looked at this
in the American context,
the most philosemitic
country in the world.
What did we find?
We found that Israeli military operations,
the weeks in which Israeli
military operations took place,
was the most important substantive factor
in explaining antisemitic
incident variation here
in the United States.
Total incidents increased by
roughly 24% in those weeks,
but what's critical here is
that violent incidents
increased by 33%, right?
There's a connection
between Israeli violence
and antisemitic violence
here in the United States.
And then on a college campus,
I think it's important
to show this research
because a lot of concern
about anti-Zionism takes place
on college campuses.
Jews, when compared to
other minority groups
on college campuses,
are more likely to experience hate crimes.
And when you look at some of the events
or characteristics of a campus
that might explain antisemitic
incident variation,
we see that the celebration
of Israel Apartheid Week,
the commemoration of
Israel Apartheid Week,
and the presence of an active SJP chapter,
both tied, of course, to the
Israeli-Palestinian conflict,
helped to predict increased antisemitism.
So, I wanna go into my own work now
on "Blame Attribution and the
Responsibility to Speak Out."
The idea here is that when
we see Jews being targeted
for the actions of Israel,
is it because perpetrators blame Jews?
Is there a feeling that
Jews, the diaspora,
have a responsibility
to speak out against
the actions of Israel?
What is the mechanism
that explains the decision
to engage in this behavior?
So our research questions
are diaspora communities
or those groups that are linked
with international actors,
blamed for the actions of their home
or an associated international act.
Are diaspora communities or groups linked
with international actors?
Are they believed to have a responsibility
to speak out against their homeland?
And is this a case
of these phenomena only
focus focusing on Jews?
Our diaspora Jews uniquely blamed
for the actions of their homeland
and the only group responsible
to speak out against them.
How do we do this?
We designed a survey.
What we did is we utilized
these experimental vignettes.
What we did is we used an
image of an apartment building
and a hospital that was
damaged in the bombing,
but we changed who the target
and the perpetrator was.
On the first story, you
see Israel bombing Gaza.
On the second, you see
Russia bombing Mariupol.
On the third, you see Saudi
Arabia bombing Sana, the end.
We also have another image of
ISIS operating in Afghanistan.
We asked our survey respondents,
"On a scale of one to 10,
how much are the diaspora
or the linked group to blame
for actions and policies
towards the target group?"
So how might this manifest?
In a series of questions, right,
we didn't just ask
about Israel's actions
towards the Palestinians,
but in those series, how much
are American Jews to blame
for Israel's actions in policies
towards the Palestinians?
Provide us with answer
on a scale of one to 10,
same question, but designed
to also capture responsibility
to speak out.
What do we find?
Well, when we look at
attribution of blame,
only Jews, only those that were exposed
to the Israel treatment,
see an increase in blame
as a treatment effect.
Not American Russians that were treated
with the Russian treatment,
not the Saudi Arabia and ISIS
treatments that we provided.
This does not increase
American Muslims being blamed, just Jews.
This is a breakdown by ideology.
I think, this is critical to show in part
because one of the subfindings
that I'm happy to go
into in the Q&A,
but what we see is that
those on the far right,
actually see a reduction
in blame towards Jews,
and see a significant increase
in blame towards Muslims,
when they're exposed
to our Israel (indistinct)
our Israel treatment.
We see similar phenomena when it comes
to the attribution of
responsibility to speak up.
Again, only the Israel treatment results
in a significant increase in the idea
that Jews have a
responsibility to speak out,
against that linked international
act, in this case, Israel.
This is, again, a
breakdown of responsibility
to speak out by ideology.
I think, it's useful.
On the left, we're looking
at it broken down by Jews,
Muslims, and Russians.
On the right, we're looking
at it broken down by ideology.
So, to give you a brief
finding summary here,
blame of diasporas for
associated conflicts,
is relatively low across the board.
While applied responsibility
substantively higher,
we were surprised by this.
Blame and responsibility,
they don't seem to operate
on the same scales.
Only Jews, those exposed
to our Israel treatment,
see a significant increase in
both blame and responsibility.
Those on the right, broadly speaking,
blame Muslims more than
any other ideology,
blames any other diaspora or linked group.
Those on the left believe
Jews are blameworthy
and responsible to speak out
more than Muslims or Russians.
And building on recent
scholarship examining antisemitism
on the extremes,
what we're really finding here is
that the effects of the
treatment are manifesting
in the greatest substantive fashion
on the ideological extremes.
This treatment effect is
magnified on our political pulse.
And I wanna introduce you to
just one other experiment,
"Hate Crime Exposure &
Foreign Policy Preferences."
We know that hate crime
reporting has gone up.
There's greater media
exposure to hate crimes.
This is an image of a CNN report,
examining antisemitic hate
crimes in the United States.
We know how hate crimes
affect the target population,
but what does it do?
How does it alter policy
preferences at a national level?
We ask, "How does exposure
to antisemitic hate crimes,
alter foreign policy
preferences, not amongst Jews,
but looking at a nationally
representative sample?"
Specifically, does exposure
to antisemitic hate crime,
alter foreign policy
preferences towards Israel?
And even more specifically,
does it manifest in certain
elements of foreign policy?
Is this something that's gonna be specific
to a general alliance?
Something that we associate
perhaps with military aid
or preferential trade?
We provided a series of
vignettes to our respondents,
one that focuses on a vandalism attack,
one that focuses on a physical attack.
We also vary what the motivation was.
In some cases, the perpetrator
is graffitiing death to Jews.
In some cases, it's death to Israel.
Same with the statement,
and the physical attack,
death to Jews or death to Israel.
We also change the identity
of the perpetrator.
All factors that we think might help
to explain variation in
foreign policy preferences.
So, how do we ask this?
How do we begin to assess foreign policy?
We ask, in your opinion,
how important is it for the United States
to maintain a strong alliance with Israel?
But we also ask that same question
of a battery of other countries.
We ask them to indicate
their level of support
for US military assistance.
We ask them to indicate
their level of support
for preferential trade with this Israel,
and again, a series of other countries.
What do we find?
We find that those that are exposed
to hate crime across the board,
find it more important
to provide military assistance to Israel.
They find it more important
to have a general alliance with Israel.
to provide preferential
trade agreements for Israel.
And we're wondering why,
why is this taking place?
What are we seeing?
Is this manifesting because
of a sense of personal threat?
So we're exposing people
to this treatment,
we're exposing them to
a story of a hate crime.
Does it make them feel
personally threatened to do that?
We don't find considerable evidence,
that's actually the case.
Well, does this also manifest perhaps
in feeling of increased threat
towards racial communities?
This is inducing that phenomenon.
Don't find considerable
evidence of that either.
But what we see is that
exposing our respondents
to antisemitic hate crime,
does increase a general sense of threat,
towards all religious communities,
with the exception of the
dominant religious community
in this country across the community.
So those that are exposed
to the hate crimes when
compared to our control group,
right, feel that there's
considerable threat,
towards religious communities
in the United States.
So, to just go over briefly
finding summary here,
exposure to antisemitic
attacks caused strong support
for pro-Israel policies
relative to the control group.
Outgroup exposure to hate crime
increases perceived support
through the victim group,
at least via preferences
that we measured vis-a-vis
associated foreign policies,
in their wake.
And what's so critical here,
is a baked normative consequence.
It suggests that those that
are committing acts of hate,
are actually generating policy preferences
and potential support for policies
that presumably they oppose.
Doing a lot of really interesting
future survey work, again,
trying to utilize this as an approach
to examine antisemitism
and the mechanisms of
antisemitism in critical ways,
focusing on elements of
conspiracy, whiteness,
hope and cooperation,
comparative prejudice.
So not just focusing on
antisemitism specifically,
utilizing specific message testing,
and also focusing on the
effectiveness of interventions.
And I wanna close with this work
that was recently done
in our 2022 ADL survey.
We asked respondents,
"Do you think this
individual pictured here
who may be the Jewish singer from Israel,
the singer that performs
in the United States,
or an Arab singer from Iraq."
So again, to clarify here,
some people were given this treatment,
another series of people
were given this treatment,
and the last series were
given this treatment,
do you consider this person to be white?
What we found was that those who were told
that the individual picture was
a Jewish singer from Israel,
were significantly more likely
to identify the individual's wife.
Those that were given
the singer from the USA
or an Arab singer from Iraq,
no significant difference between the two.
White respondents who viewed
the Jewish-Israeli singer
as white endorsed fewer
antisemitic tropes,
than white respondents who
viewed him as non-white.
And among non-white respondents,
the perceived whiteness,
really didn't have a measurable
impact on antisemitism.
This individual is
individual is (indistinct)
He is an Iraqi-Jewish
singer living in Israel.
So I'm gonna close there,
just always close with images
of my cats and my daughter.
Any questions or concerns, comments?
Again, a lot of this
is in the early stages,
so we really welcome your support
and your work and your feedback.
Please feel free to email
me at my Gratz email.
Thank you very much for your
time, really appreciate it.
- [Maurice] Thank you, Ayal,
for that very interesting presentation.
And I know some people have written
in that there's an echo problem.
Hopefully, that's been taken care of.
We apologize, we're still trying
to figure out this technology.
- Yeah, and apologize, everybody,
for my clicker happiness throughout.
I'm sorry.
- [Maurice] Okay, so a bunch
of questions from the audience.
I have some questions too.
One quick question that just came up is,
could you explain the hyphen?
I mean, this is, you
know, in antisemitism,
this is something that always comes up
in antisemitism studies.
So, are you a hyphenate or no,
and what does that mean?
- So from the very beginning,
I would write to editors that I'm okay
with the decision of the journal
to choose how antisemitism
should be spelled.
I was never somebody that focused on this
because I felt that it took away
from more of the meaningful,
impactful research that we could be doing,
examining the manifestations
of antisemitism.
I believe there is a place
for definitional concerns of antisemitism,
and I applaud the scholars
that engage in it,
but it's not the area of focus for me.
The origin of this is commonly expressed
as related to this notion of
there being no Semitic people.
That being Semitic is actually
a language orientation.
And therefore by getting rid of the hyphen
and making it antisemitism, right,
we're making this a phenomenon
that's specific to choose.
But I'll go back to the
comment from the slide
where I talked about this very subject,
which is that many people
in the United States,
a huge proportion of people in
the United States don't know
what antisemitism is.
So this is part of a broader debate
that we need to be having
in terms of clarifying the
visibility of the subject.
- [Maurice] Okay, great.
So, a question about AI.
- Yes.
- [Maurice] Yeah.
So, can you talk a little bit
about AI-generated antisemitism?
Is this posing an even greater risk than
what we were experiencing before?
And maybe just tell for audience members
who aren't familiar with AI,
what we're talking about here.
- So first of all, I am
no expert in AI myself,
so let me make that clear.
There are some individuals that
are working on this research
that know it much better than I do.
But the idea here is that, in fact,
you can take the correlates
of antisemitic propaganda
that work the best in terms of influence,
in terms of recruitment,
and generate truly excellent
antisemitic propaganda.
It can help you,
generative AI can help you
in terms of finding the best avenue
in which to advertise this
or present this material.
It can help you in recruiting
specific individuals.
By testing this back and forth,
you can provide generative AI,
a variety of different
elements of propaganda,
and it can refine it for you.
I can tell you that this is something
that's of deep concern in
the intelligence community,
and it's worthy of studying
and evaluating further.
I can tell you that
definitely there are actors
that are utilizing AI for the purpose
of making antisemitic propaganda
and rhetoric more impactful.
- [Maurice] Thank you.
So a few questions actually
about your surveys,
and are there generational
differences in how people respond
to the survey?
How do you control for that?
- Well, we always control
for age, for education,
anything related to SCS,
we control for religion,
we control for any of
the demographic factors,
the geographic factors that are critical
in designing a nationally
representative sample.
There are some interesting
generational effects.
We see that there is not
always this linear effect
as it relates to age.
Many people assume that antisemitism,
is going to be the highest
among the oldest population.
That is not always the case.
Depends on the specific element
of antisemitism you're trying to measure.
For example, when it comes
to anti-Zionism, right,
anti-Zionism, and again,
not that all anti-Zionism is antisemitism,
but anti-Zionist, antisemitism, right,
is actually lowest amongst
the oldest generations,
and it's highest amongst the younger.
I think that comes as no
surprise to many people,
but elements of antisemitism
that are related to power,
related to economics, right?
That's oftentimes a
millennial phenomenon, right?
In part because of the exogenous factors
that they experienced as it
relates to the procession.
- [Maurice] Okay.
And so, would you say that
there are different antisemitism
in like, we're talking about
the American context right now?
- Sure.
- [Maurice] So, for instance,
we have what's going on
arguably on college campuses,
but that seems to me anyway very different
from Orthodox Jews on the streets
in Brooklyn getting attacked.
So, how do your surveys get
at those different kinds of antisemitism?
Because it strikes me that, you know,
it's picking up something,
but it's maybe not picking
up those differences.
- So yeah, I think that
there are different elements
of why Jews might be targeted
for specific behavior.
First of all, when we think
about the broader structure possible,
you have to be able to
identify a perpetrator, right?
If you're able to identify a target,
perpetrator needs to identify a target.
When you identify a
specific target, right,
when we think about Jews, right,
not all Jews are going to be
identifiable to a perpetrator.
There's not an even distribution
of Jewish institutions
that can be targeted.
So specific areas
where there's a higher
concentration views,
including American college campuses,
are gonna see, let's say,
an increased likelihood
of antisemitic hate crime
as a consequence.
That's going to be different, right,
than areas that have fewer Jews.
When it comes to thinking about this topic
from a visibly Jewish standpoint,
thinking about let's say
orthodox or rhetoric communities,
yes, we note that there's
higher likelihood of hate crimes
that are targeting those individuals.
When asking those individuals
about their experience,
they're more likely to say
that they experience antisemitic
rhetoric being the victims
of an antisemitic incident.
So again, this all plays a role
in the likelihood of a primary state.
- [Maurice] And do you see
that there's more measurable antisemitism
on college campuses with
greater Jewish populations?
- So we find that yes, the
larger the Jewish population,
the greater the number of
incidents that are being reported.
We find that the proportion of Jews,
so when we think about it
from a percentage standpoint,
that's not a great predictor
of explaining antisemitic
incidents on campus.
So you need a certain critical mass Jews
to experience considerable antisemitism.
- [Maurice] But you do find
that on college campuses,
and that's true kind of across the board.
Like, it really correlates that, or is it,
how have you guys, you know,
who's studying that and what have they?
- There's lots of research
that's really trying
to examine this issue.
The work that I did was a project for AN.
What I did is I looked at
Hillel International's report
on Jewish populations across
different institutions.
We looked at the incident rates
that have been reported,
and we evaluated whether or
not there was a relationship,
between the size of the Jewish population
at that institution as well as prestige,
as well as geographic
characteristics, acceptance rates.
We looked at a variety
of different cohorts,
but we found that one
of the most important predictive factors
of whether or not an institution,
would see heightened
antisemitism was, of course,
the size of the Jewish population.
- [Maurice] Okay, here's a question
that I'm not sure you'll
be able to answer,
but I'd love to just hear
what you think, which is,
if Israel weren't in the picture,
would the incidents of
antisemitism still be on the rise?
Is it impossible to separate the two?
- I love and hate counterfactuals.
If Israel wasn't here, would
incidents still be on the rise?
What I'd say is that it's really important
that we don't think about anti-Zionism
and anti-Israel sentiment.
It's something that exists exclusively
with one ideological domain.
One of the things that I often do,
I didn't do it in this presentation,
is I show two vehemently
anti-Zionist quotes.
One coming from Louis Farrakhan
and the other coming
from Matthew Heimbach,
who's a relatively infamous neo-Nazi here
in the United States.
Again, the idea here is
that antisemitism
doesn't exist exclusively
in specific ideological
domains, it doesn't.
I think, anti-Zionism specifically,
and anti-Zionism antisemitism
is a convenient way
to manifest certain
elements of antisemitism
in a more socially acceptable way.
It's not always that case,
but I think it's a useful
tool for that reason.
If Israel wasn't here,
would we see it on the rise?
I don't know, obviously,
and I would refute anybody
that says that they do.
But antisemitism has
existed for millennia,
so I imagine it would still be here.
And the most infamous
incidents of antisemitism
in this country existed
part of creation of Israel.
- [Maurice] And so a lot of your studies,
are the ones you showed today reflected,
we're trying to control
or trying to examine incident
antisemitic feelings,
according to political positions.
- Yeah.
- [Maurice] But what about,
are you studying or is
anybody studying the effect
of family background or
levels of stress and anxiety
in the home or things like that
and how that contributes to antisemitic?
So more kind of psychological profiles.
- Of the perpetrators?
- [Maurice] Of perpetrators, yeah.
- Yeah, that's a really
interesting question.
I think, it's hard to get
access to that data, right?
First thing, when we
think about hate crimes
and reported hate crimes,
we look at reports that are
coming from policing agencies.
The number of hate crime prosecutions
in this country is remarkably low.
So those that we can
really definitively say,
are perpetrators of a hate crime,
using that definition of being
convicted of a hate crime.
Profiles on that sense are
really mostly available
in a comparative sense,
in a qualitative sense,
less so a quantitative sense.
Are there specific elements
of someone's upbringing
that makes them more likely
to potentially engage
in antisemitic behavior?
We can look to some of the work
from perpetrators themselves
reporting on this issue,
sense of loneliness, and needing to belong
in a non-nuclear family structure.
These are things
that explain hate crime
perpetration potentially,
but they also explain
all crime perpetration.
So it's really hard to disentangle this.
- [Maurice] Yeah, and
I've heard Günther Jikeli,
you know, some of his research
which has shown that maybe,
you know, counterintuitively, you know,
levels of poverty didn't really
see in studying antisemitism
in European-Muslim communities.
It wasn't correlated necessarily
with socioeconomic background,
but much more with exposure to
extreme religious ideologies.
So, okay, we're basically out of time,
but I wanted to end on
maybe a more hopeful note
by what research is being done
and which solutions work best
for solving antisemitism or making it
at least a little bit better?
- I think, there's a really big push now
to try to figure out
antisemitism interventions,
ways in which we can reduce
both the causes of antisemitism,
how we can generate policy
that prevents the
manifestations of antisemitism,
the behavior, and then also, right,
how do we assess the
effectiveness of these elements,
of these policies, of these interventions?
A lot of this is being
done through education.
There's actually really
amazing work that's being done
by Joshua Cowell and David Brooklyn,
that I'll let them speak to
because I don't believe it's yet out.
But they're doing fantastic
work evaluating the various ways
in which one can intervene
to reduce antisemitism
from both an educational
and a policy perspective.
There's a question of
whether contact is going
to be effective, if it's a
specific-type of contact.
Again, I showed you some of the work
on that from the Polish contexts.
I can tell you that from working
with some scholars in Norway,
the Pathfinders programs,
specifically what they've
done is expose individuals
to Norwegian Jews,
communities that normally don't
have Norwegian Jews focusing
on the Norwegian elements
of that Jewish individual's experience.
And they see a considerable
reduction in antisemitism,
but also, prejudice towards
other minority groups
and marginalized groups in Norway.
So there are avenues
that are being explored,
but it's widely understood,
amongst the scholars setting antisemitism
that this is the area
that's received the
least rigorous attention.
- [Maurice] Okay, terrific.
Well, thank you so much for
your really enlightening talk,
and thank you to everyone in the audience
for your questions.
I urge everybody,
if you're not ready to please get
on the GIPSA or YPSA mailing list.
We have a lot of interesting
programming this year,
and look forward to seeing
you all future events.
So please join me in
thanking Ayal Feinberg.